>> THERE'S A LOT GOING ON RIGHT
NOW, BUT THE IDEA WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, CLICK A
SWITCH, BRING DOWN THE COST OF
GASOLINE, IS NOT LIKELY IN THE
NEAR TERM, NOR IS IT WITH REGARD
TO FOOD.
>> Katie: WELL, PRESIDENT BIDEN
CLEARLY HAS NO IDEA HOW TO SOLVE
THE INFLATION CRISIS AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE CAN'T
STOP CONTRADICTING HIM ON WHAT
HE KNOWS ABOUT THE BIG ISSUES
FACING AMERICANS.
AS MILLIONS STRUGGLE TO FIND
BABY FORMULA ON SHELVES, BIDEN
REVEALING HE WAS NOT AWARE OF
THE CRISIS UNTIL APRIL DESPITE
PREVIOUS CLAIMS FROM WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS THAT THEY HAD BEEN
WORKING ON THE ISSUE FOR MONTHS.
>> WELL, HERE'S THE DEAL.
I BECAME AWARE OF THIS PROBLEM
SOMETIME IN -- AFTER APRIL, IN
EARLY APRIL, ABOUT HOW INTENSE
IT WAS.
>> Katie: SO, JESSICA, THE TIME
LINE THEY SAID THEY STARTED
WORKING ON IT IN FEBRUARY,
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE
JUST BASICALLY FOUND OUT ABOUT
IT, THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
>> Jessica: IT IS FEASIBLE THAT
THERE WERE PEOPLE WORKING ON IT
AND THE FDA WAS INVOLVED BECAUSE
THEY TRIGGERED THE WHOLE RECALL
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
NONE OF THE ANSWERS ARE OKAY AND
THE JUDGE AND I WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY AS A MOM
AND A NEW GRANDMOTHER, THAT THE
MEETING OF THE CEOs OF THE
FORMULA COMPANIES YESTERDAY WAS
THE MOST INFURIATING THING I'VE
EVER SEEN WHERE THEY ALL
ADMITTED THAT THEY KNEW THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN
THE ABBOTT RECALL WAS COMING
DOWN THE PIPE.
AND WHEN YOUR PRODUCT, AND I
UNDERSTAND EVERYONE, YOU KNOW,
GOOD CAPITALISTS, WANT TO MAKE
GOOD MONEY, YOUR PRODUCT SERVES
A REALLY IMPORTANT PURPOSE.
RIGHT THIS IS ISN'T BEDAZZLED
KEY CHAINS THIS IS KEEPING KIDS
ALIVE.
THERE IS NO OTHER OPTION FOR
CHILDREN THAN TO BE ON FORMULA
IN MANY CASES.
AND I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ON
TWITTER ABOUT HOW I SHOULD JUST
START BREAST FEEDING AGAIN.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING HERE.
>> Greg: YOU'RE NOT ON TWITTER
>> Jessica: THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD HOPE WOULD HAPPEN.
I AM ON TWITTER, IT IS UGLY OUT
THERE BUT I AM ON TWITTER.
I THINK YOU EVEN FOLLOW ME.
ANYWAY IT'S REALLY BAD AND FOR
MANY PEOPLE AND MOMS ESPECIALLY,
THIS IS EQUAL TO THE GAS CRISIS,
AND IT'S EVERYDAY.
I CANNOT GET IN THE CAR, I
CANNOT AVOID GOING HOME AND
FEEDING MY KID.
>> Katie: I THINK IT'S WORSE
THAN THE GAS.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS WORSE
BECAUSE IT'S A LIFE LINE AND BY
THE WAY SOME WOMEN DON'T
LACTATE.
>> Greg: I DON'T LACTATE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE MEN DON'T
LACTATE.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A COMPANY LIKE
ABBOTT, AND THERE ARE SO FEW
COMPANIES THAT ACTUALLY MAKE
BABY FOOD IN AMERICA, FOUR OF
THEM, YOU CAN'T FIGURE OUT THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DROUGHT IN
BABY FORMULA THEN YOU'RE JUST
STUPID.
AND FOR YOU NOT TO GIVE ANY KIND
OF CONFIDENCE OR HOPE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY, I ONLY
LEARNED ABOUT THIS IN APRIL WHEN
THEY COMPLAINED THE WHISTLE
BLOWER IN OCTOBER, YOU DIDN'T
GET YOUR BUTT IN GEAR UNTIL
DECEMBER, MADE AN APPOINTMENT IN
JANUARY, DIDN'T MAKE A DECISION
UNTIL FEBRUARY.
ALL OF THEM ARE SO SLOW AND SO
BEHIND IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY DO.
THERE'S NO INITIATIVE.
THERE'S NO CARING THERE.
AND WHAT THEY HAVE DONE, AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION JUST LIES
ABOUT, WELL, WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE PRESS SECRETARY HERE, I
DON'T KNOW IF I FEEL SORRY FOR
HER OR WHAT, BUT SHE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT KNOWS.
>> Katie: YEAH.
JESSE IT'S DEFINITELY A REFLEX
OF CLUNKY BAUER ROCK ARREST AND
THE FDA ESPECIALLY NOT
FORESEEING THIS CRISIS WHEN THEY
DECIDED TO SHIP DOWN THE PLANT
>> Jesse: REMEMBER THEY COULDN'T
INTERVIEW THE WHISTLE BLOWER FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS BECAUSE THE
WHISTLE BLOWER'S SCHEDULE WAS
TOO JAMMED.
ALL RIGHT?
SO BIDEN WAS MADE AWARE OF THIS
IN APRIL, THEN WHY DID HE WAIT
UNTIL, I DON'T KNOW, LAST WEEK
TO START FLYING IN FORMULA FROM
EUROPE?
WHY DID HE WAIT UNTIL A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO TO INVOKE THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT.
HE SAID WHAT THE TIME LINE IS SO
THE NEXT QUESTION IS MR.
PRESIDENT WHY DID YOU WAIT A
MONTH AND A HALF TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
HE DIDN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
I WENT FORMULA SHOPPING TODAY,
EMMA SAID PICK UP SOME JUGS.
I WENT TO WALGREENS, SHE SAID
GET SERVICE YOU CAN.
I WENT AND THERE'S NOTHING ON
THE SHELVES.
>> Katie: THERE ARE NO JUGS?
>> Jesse: THE STUFF I GET FOR MY
BABY.
SO THERE WAS FOUR JUGS AND I
THINK TO MYSELF
>> Jessica: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
JUGS?
IT'S JUST A REGULAR BOTTLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: DON'T CALL IT
A JUG.
>> Jesse: WHAT SHOULD I CALL IT?
>> Jessica: BOTTLE.
>> Jesse: IT'S A JUG IT'S BIG.
THERE'S FOUR AND I SAID SHOULD I
HOARD?
I ONLY GOT TWO, AND SHE SAID YOU
ONTO GOT TWO SO SHE WENT AND GOT
THE LAST TWO SO NOW THERE'S
NOTHING LEFT.
>> Katie: THEY SAY THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON IT SINCE FEBRUARY AND
THEY SAY LOOK AT THE RESULTS
EVEN THOUGH THE RESULTS ARE A A
DISASTER.
>> Greg: HERE IS THE GOOD NEWS.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN SAID HE
DOESN'T SEE THE FOOD CRISIS
GOING DOWN IN THE NEAR FUTURE,
HE DIDN'T SEE AFGHANISTAN
PULLOUT DISASTER, DIDN'T SEE THE
BABY FORMULA DISASTER, THE CRIME
WAVE.
SO IF HE SAYS HE DOESN'T SEE THE
PRICES GOING DOWN, THEY'RE GOING
TO GO DOWN, BECAUSE HE'S ALWAYS
WRONG.
>> Jesse: LIKE MURPHY'S LAW.
>> Greg: HE'S ALWAYS WRONG.
THE UP SIDE IS I THINK THE
INEPTITUDE IS EDUCATING MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ON THE FRUITLESSNESS
OF VIRTUE SIGNALING AND IDENTITY
POLITICS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
REMIND YOURSELF ALL THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS THAT WENT IGNORED IS
BECAUSE THEY LISTENED TO THE
LEFT WHO PLACED THEIR
TWITTER-SHAPED CONCERNS IN FRONT
OF REAL CONCERNS.
SO IT WASN'T ABOUT INFLATION OR
CRIME OR THE BORDER.
IT WAS ABOUT TRANS IN THE
MILITARY, DEBT CANCELLATION,
PRONOUNCE, STATUS, SCHOOL NAMES.
THAT BECAME THE BASE OF THE
PARTY.
AND THIS IS WHY OUR SHOW'S SO
POPULAR BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE REAL STUFF AND PEOPLE
ARE LEARNING LIKE HOW DID WE GET
SOLD THIS BILL OF GOODS ON THESE
OTHER CHANNELS THAT WERE TALKING
ABOUT IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE
STATUS COMING DOWN.
IF WE SPENT LESS TIME PULLING
DOWN STATUS AND MORE TIME TAKING